hi my name is Leah and I am the owner of
milk farm artisan tree shop in Eagle
Rock California I have been in the food
industry for 20 years and 12 of those
years have been specifically in cheese
tasty thinks they could stump me with a
BuzzFeed cheese quiz let's get started
most people can't identify seven cheeses
on this picture
can you yeah well I'm looking at this
one on the right and I'm gonna guess
that this is the cheddar but I kind of
don't appreciate the way it's cut but
I'm gonna guess that the cheddar is this
one so the next one says click on Swiss
and I'm going to guess it is this one Oh
see this is kind of a trick because in
our shop when people asked for Swiss we
specifically say do you mean the Swiss
with holes that have eyes or do you mean
a traditional Alpine style cheese so the
one I just clicked on looks like an
Alpine style cheese which is what I
would consider Swiss cheese that was an
accident
okay the next one says click on a feta
okay process of elimination now I'm not
gonna jump the gun I'm gonna look at all
the cheese's just that one because it's
quite crumbly um mozzarella is that one
mozzarella this is a fresh mozzarella
click on gorgonzola mm-hmm
is this really gorgonzola picante I
think that this should be changed should
just click on the blue cheese the next
one says click on Colby jack second
right here I was actually gonna name my
dog Colby jack provolone
next one's parmesan this guy right here
parmesan if you're getting grilled
parmesan from Italy it would be called
parmigiano-reggiano and parmesan made
outside of Italy could be called
parmesan you can tell that it's real
because it actually has the etchings on
it click on the Brie
I don't like the way this is worded
because I know it's this one but this is
not BRE this looks like burpee roost
argent hall so I don't know I feel like
this is a trick question
who wrote this test I would never do
this I'm gonna guess that you guys would
say this one click on Havarti I'm gonna
click this one over here all right the
one with a really beautiful mint on the
top click on Muenster now it's this
supermarket monster and I've like big
block slicey monster or like the stinky
one I'm gonna guess that your guys are
thinking it's this one cuz the other one
I'm thinking that you might choose that
one for a Gouda okay click on a goat
cheese that's easy because a lot of
people always associate goat cheese with
really soft white spreadable cheese and
that's what's pictured right here click
on manchego no this one here that's very
obvious
manchego is always made with Lamantia
sheep's milk from the La Mancha region
in Spain you could tell this in the
manchego because of these esparto grass
actions that you see on the outside and
I knew it click on the Gouda it's this
one right here this one looks like
smoked gouda click on a Conte this is
the one that messed me up I got 14 out
of 15 it says that I'm a true cheese
monger which is true I guess whether
it's Swiss or Stilton you're definitely
a cheese connoisseur you know more about
cheese then roughly 95% of humanity yeah
this is a really fun test I can't
believe that most people can only get 7
out of 15 that means I need to work a
little bit harder to spread the gospel
of cheese
and apply to be a cheese monger because
it's a great job I wonder if I should
make my employees take this test I think
it would be fun I think that that would
actually score 14 or 15 I think every
single one of them would
[Music]